what's going on guys national master james canty
the third here with chess.com and today we have
game of the day with the white pieces we have
daniel duvall and with the black pieces we have
sergey karyakin this is the russian super finals
and if karyakin is able to win this game he takes
so first of the russian super finals guys he's
the champ now of course duvall is not going to
let that happen he's going to play his best
and say you're going to have to get through
me says duboff and here we are e4 e5 knight
f3 and knight to c6 bishop c4 and bishop c5
very easy game could be an evans gambit it could
be a joko piano something like that italian game
type stuff but after bishop c5 there's c3 from
duval then knight f6 i'm going smooth so far
stuff that they've seen before nothing spectacular
d4 is the usual move here intending after he takes
d4 we're going to see c takes d4 you know kind of
an easy game sometimes you can play d3 here but
what happens is he takes d4 usual move and here
guys what would you actually play there are there
are a few alternatives e5 castling be a move and c
takes d4 right these are the usual moves here but
this is what daniel duboff played here he played
something completely different and the highest
rated player to play this move right here guys
can you find the move that was played right here
here we go guys this is the move b4 can you
believe it before i've never actually seen this
myself so this is definitely some home cooking
some prep that he's done to throw uh sergey
karyakin off here i mean this was amazing to play
b4 now let's watch the follow-ups here now after
b4 there is bishop to b6 and then e5 is played now
instead of earlier which is usually played here
the best defense is offense and just because i'm
attacked doesn't mean i have to move my piece so
after e5 actually d5 is the most thematic way to
play sergey did not do d5 here and let's actually
take a look at what happens if d5 happens f takes
e takes f6 is the best way to play d takes c4 then
queen e2 and bishop e6 and then after b5 making a
threat on the knight knight moves out of the way
f takes g7 rook g8 we take on d4 queen d7 and this
is supposed to be what the position would look
like if they went down that road with black being
slightly better at actually preparing to castle
queenside but that's actually not what happened
at all it was actually knight to e4 by sergey
karyakin here now after 94 there's a bunch of ways
to play guys you have castle c takes d4 do we play
b5 like what are we playing here what what's the
move like what do we actually do here well let
uh let's let daniel to tell you guys what he did
here at the neil bishop to d5 actually bishop d5
this is the most aggressive way to play here it's
going to get pretty fun now let's see what happens
here he must capture the second pawn here yeah he
has to go into this line because there's really
not nothing else to do here now after bishop to
d5 knight takes c3 from karaoke knight takes c3
d takes c3 and here we go guys when you're on
the attack when you gambit something when you're
down material or you sacrifice something for rapid
development gambits and things like that you need
to keep the attack up so what would you do to keep
the attack up in this move guys would you castle
would you play like b5 would you play a4 what
would you actually play in this moment here we
go guys here's the move bishop g5 and this is
also a novelty here now it seems like bishop g5
just an easy move to make i mean i would play this
too because like we're attacking a queen it's a
good move but he keeps attacking if black if if uh
duboff waits for black to castle here then queen
e8 could be a move so you want to get bishop g5
in easily now black must allow this pin to happen
and then 97 this seems very cramped for right here
not the most fun position and here we go after 97
there's castles then there's h6 because he says
look this pin has to go i am tired of this pin
so the bishop backs up and says not today and if
you want to get rid of this pin you're going to
have to play g5 and we're going to get very live
after g5 and now it's going to be messed up over
here especially if you're trying to castle on this
side of the board so at the bishop h4 we have uh
castles very natural move but now uh white loves
engine the the attack here well the engines love
white's attack after these next few moves after
castles there's rook to e8 guys just putting some
pressure on the file maybe even some rook lifts
maybe e6 could be in the future you never know
it's always good to put a rook on e8 here but the
development for black is not it's not there it's
not existing a little bit for white too on this
side but we have the bishop swiping the boy here
and this knight can come into play eventually
maybe through e5 and maybe we can have some type
of queen play let's see what happens after rookie
eight there is queen to e8 he says you know what i
am tired of this pin and denial plays bishop to b3
backing it all the way up maybe bishop to c2 this
could happen too as well white is definitely
in the driver's seat here guys now watch this
a5 happens and says look we need to make something
happen let's make some trades let's do something
i need to get my pieces out now white to move guys
make sure you're on your attacking brain today
hopefully you did your tactics in puzzle
rush on chess.com now check this out what
would you play as white right here i'm going to
give you a few seconds to figure this one out
what would you play as white right now here we go
guys a5 after a5 white plays this move right here
bishop to f6 can you believe that move right
there bishop f6 is on the board against sergey
karaoke imagine if you are sergey karyakin right
now how do you feel pressure wise that i have
to win this game to be champ and i'm now getting
bishop f6 played on me on the board bishop f6 is
a scary move it's very very scary move here guys
and of course the idea here is after pawn takes
pawn takes and this is pin and not only is the
king side busted open now but you have problems
and also i'm getting my piece back with some
interest here so bishop f6 great attacking idea
now after bishop f6 there's a4 on the board
here which was not the best move they said
um that uh knight f5 actually was it was an entry
something to do here but he plays a4 honestly
because this is a scary position to be in after
a4 there's bishop to c4 now myself i would have
probably played bishop to c2 and play queen
d3 and go in this fashion but bishop c4 keeps
the pin here is what he wanted to do bishop c4
then you see knight to g6 and queen to d3 guys
we're attacking this knight this bishop is pinning
the pawn your pieces don't exist says duboff
queen to d3 actually and after queen d3 there's
d5 i have to do something here and if this is
the best move to make you might be in some
trouble here now after d5 here we go he takes d6
your queen is hanging oh and your knight is
hanging oh and you need something else to do
this bishop is hanging as well watch this guys
bishop to e6 is on the board are you ready for
today i hope you came ready to watch this video
today now i want you to stop the video right now
and tell me what you would play if
you were do ball in this position
hope you guys are ready here it is here it
is guys this is the move of the day move of
the year guys watch this combination
here is it if you said queen takes g6
bam oh my goodness there it is in sergey karaoke
and you can probably see him sweating immediately
after this move maybe flew back in his chair like
in the matrix or something queen takes g6 happened
on the board and it was a loud loud clap clatter
after clapping the piece there it was amazing
queen takes g6 is on the board and he just stood
up and looked at karaoke probably did in his head
he didn't really do that but i'm sure he probably
wanted to queen takes g6s on the board sacrificing
the queen guys and after f takes g6 rook takes
e6 to follow right after here we have all of this
i in him i mean this is very scary right now
now we got our material back we have discoveries
against the king well now he has two pieces for
the queen says duboff and we have an attack let's
see what happens queen f7 he just kind of gets out
of the way here there's discoveries everywhere so
he just kind of blocks the discovery here and says
okay cool yeah you have a little bit of material
we're not going to give you everything here's
what white does guys watch the follow-up here
when you sacrifice and you do things like this
you want to wait and you want to actually look
and see what's your follow-up and you need to
know beforehand before you actually get to this
position and be wrong so you want to have your
follow-up ahead of time and this is what he did
what he does here guys bishop takes c3 there
is no need to hurry black can't move the queen
and the king off the a2 g8 diagonal
it's just very hard to do this so
bishop takes c3 he just gets out of the way here
no need to no need to hurry and then king h80
says look i have to get off of this as quickly
as possible but then here we go rookie four now
we defend the queen here and if you look at the
compensation here guys compensation is very very
important one of the hardest things to explain in
chess is compensation uh yeah i'm losing my queen
i've sacrificed it for a little bit of material
but i mean we have our minor pieces we have two
bishops in the night and we have two rooks and
a attack against the black king here this should
be enough compensation here guys especially as
strong as daniel is playing sergey karyakin it
could be wild here and of course uh daniel is
known for these type of positions and attacking
an aggressive play so let's see what happens rook
to e4 queen f5 attacking the rook here you got to
keep the attacks up as white does the same thing
you keep attacking i'm going to keep attacking two
as well says daniel rookie seven hitting g7 guys
this is very scary the bishops in the rook work
together brilliantly now after rook to e7 here
it is rook g8 because he kind of has to i mean
you have to defend g7 there's all kind of attacks
mating threats mating ideas so he says okay cool
you're going to give me the rook i'm going to take
it now we have two rooks and two pieces and maybe
even a past pawn here versus these these pieces
here which doesn't look that good guys it doesn't
look that good d takes c7 now i have almost a
queen here and i have some pieces all i have to
do is trade probably one of the rooks or a bishop
and we're definitely in the driver's seat here
after d take c7 he plays queen to c2 here just
keeping some threats on the board because this
is not looking that good for segay kariakin he
understands that so now bishop to e5 we defend
the c7 pawn with aspirations of queening later
on now after uh king bishop e5 bishop takes f2
he just takes the pawn because it's with check
you need to do something and then the king just
steps over king 2h1 and bishop back to b6 so
now after bishop b6 we have a uh h3 on the board
king h7 and rookie one guys activating the last
piece now the rooks are doubled on the file here
this is usually what you want to do when you have
rooks against the queen here and then we have some
attacks maybe we're going for rook to e2 removing
the bishop from somewhere moving it somewhere
maybe even bishop f6 and also playing rook to
e7 so there's many moves to go here but let's
see what happens a3 was played what he's trying to
do now is take on a2 and try to have his own pass
pawn of his own because this is not looking that
good this rook is only a defensive piece on g7
the bishop's still doing the same thing defensive
wise trying to keep an eye on this and the queen
is i mean all the pieces that black has here
kerry hawkins is only on defense at this point
what a queen sack sacrificed by duboff king 2h2
and then we have g5 on the boy here just trying
to make some holes for the king and do something
here maybe queen back to g6 but as we're we're
running out of moves we are running out of moves
on the other hand white's actually getting closer
to the king knight to d4 followed by knight to f5
or e6 putting more pressure on the g7 pawn knight
uh queen to f queen to c4 then we have knight of
five threatening g7 queen takes b4 hitting this
rook this rook is completely defended here what
he plays is rook to c1 hey we're about to clean
okay this compensation is beautiful if you watch
how all the pieces play together it's hard to play
against all of these pieces when you don't have
enough material even having a queen is not enough
sometimes and that's exactly the case here in this
game rook to c1 king to g6 he's out of the way
and here it is guys duval says look it's time to
cash in this this advantage okay it's time to show
everybody this queen sack did work and after
king take queen king to g6 rook takes g7 check
so now forcing a rook takes here i mean of course
if king takes f5 which actually did happen but if
rick takes g7 we just queen anyway so karaoke says
okay you know what i have to take the knight and
then rook takes g8 not only are we we are about to
queen now now we have two rooks versus a queen and
he only has a queen and a bishop that's nothing
bishop takes c7 and bishop takes c7 now after the
dust settles here there's two rooks in the bishop
versus the queen this is more than enough um for
the win actually for white let's find a few more
moves here queen to b2 attacking the rook rook
to c5 check his king is getting very very short
on spaces he goes king to e4 and then rook to d8
and then karaoke looked up he looked around he
took a sip of water he put it back down he looked
at duval looked down at the position and then
black resigned right here black resigned right
here because there was really nothing else to do a
sample line would be something like queen takes a2
and then after rookie five check king to f4 rook
to d4 is checkmate so there's really kind of no
way out of these things and there's there's other
variations that can happen here but he realized
where he was i don't have enough my kings looking
crazy in the middle of the street i have nothing
around my king i'm probably going to be mated
with the two rooks in a bishop or if not losing
some decisive material meaning the queen here
at the end guys so really really nasty game here
let's actually go back and with the key critical
moment and by the way anyone that does play the
yoko piano even myself because i love playing the
scotch gambit i'm going to try this out with this
new b4 and see how far we can get here because do
both loves giving us something new here and after
b4 e5 94 bishop d5 nice little sacrifice here
bishop g5 i mean nastiness here castles bishop
h4 and let's fast forward guys the best move was
right here this was the absolute best move was
here we go here it is queen takes g6 didn't even
care about anything here i mean you you would
probably take here you would look at this move
you would look at this move but queen takes g6
is just phenomenal guys queen takes g6 rook takes
e6 and now it's a party it's a party guys it's
a party look at this this was awesome this was
absolutely awesome dude put on a show here and
stopped karaoke from winning the russian super
final championship guys now this was game of the
day i'm national master james cancer iii here with
chess.com and i'll see you guys on the next video